In your opinion, what can be roadblocks
to the Active Network's Vision? And I'm going to
give you multiple choices. And you can pick more than one choice if you think it
fits the answer to this question. The
first choice is that the active network's vision
needs buy-in from the router vendors. Router vendors
are vendors like Cisco. Who make the routing
fabric and the first choice is saying it
need, you, you need buy in from the router
vendors, the second choice is saying that because
the routing was active network is happening in software,
the software routing speed cannot match the throughput
needed in the internet core. That's the second choice,
the third choice says that. It makes the internet
more vulnerable, and the fourth choice says that it
makes the router more susceptible to code spoofing.